thank you very much thanks to the
organizers for the invitation
so I would like to talk about two
different things actually I will
slightly extend the subject of my talk
but I will start with mimicking her the
Mahal sounds so just a very quick
introduction to the notation bucket and
denotes integers from one to one
a discrete cube is just the symmetric
Cube negative one one in power n with
uniform probability measure on it
expectation with respect to this
probability measure is just arithmetic
mean of all values of the function on
the cube
LP Norm is defined in a usual way we
just compute the peace absolute moment
and take the piece out of it
we'll also consider this color product
defined in a standard way so when you
when we have two real values functions
on the cube this color product is just
expectation of the usual product so we
average overall vertices products of the
values of the functions
and this coincides with the notation for
the second norm and we'll consider the
Hilbert space of all real valued
functions on on this Discord Cube this
is finite dimensional so actually it
doesn't matter that much whether we
consider L2 normal and other Norm in
terms of topology of this space
but later on it will be useful to view
this as Hilbert space at software and
this is two in power and dimensional
heal belt space so as like 90 percent of
people here no one probably 100
people on the in the audience we can
consider Walsh functions on the descript
Cube so given a subset a in bracket and
we Define all Fourier functions wa as a
product of coordinates that fall into
the set a and w indexed by empty set is
identically one we also denote by RI
rademachers meaning Walsh functions
indexed by single atons this is just
coordinate production on the cube
so because on the cube you have a
product measure uniform product measure
this means that after projecting we will
get independent symmetric plus minus one
with
okay so that's the standard notation and
just to remind you uh the Walsh function
has expectation 0 is a is non-empty and
otherwise it has expectation one of
course because this function is
identically one
and this means that all functions form
an orthonormal system
uh
this is just an example
I I will not stop on this because all of
you know this stuff I guess
uh
uh so this means that any function and
real values function on the cube admits
the unique Fourier walls expansion so F
hat a will be just the Fourier or World
Fourier coefficient in this expansion
for function and of course we read this
coefficient just by taking scalar
product with evolves function
okay so that that was just to remind you
the basic things and to explain the
notation that I will use and now
let Capital let be some number greater
equal than two to make things
non-trivial and by VN we denote the
linear span of all Walsh functions
indexed by sets with cardinality greater
than n
so I will call them briefly high
frequencies all frequencies higher than
n
and now the thing that I would like to
describe in the first part of my talk
is related to a problem that I was asked
by several people in Poland
who is here
so for various reasons they came to me
with the following question
assume that you have a function on the
district
well they came independently actually
but the reason they came with a similar
question each of them formulating it is
slightly different way was interrelated
because they were working on singular
things and they wanted to construct a
similar thing and actually what I showed
was that what they are going to do
doesn't work
so as usually I'm
talking about negative things you know
Polish people are pessimists by Nature
I found it attractive to to exploit this
National tendency and then tell you
about the things that make the world
worse place right so we consider on the
discrete Cube just some of and
rademachers and actually the thing that
I will discuss I will only restrict to
this sort of Rademacher some actually
you can extend the methods and almost
everything that I say to generally some
but then the person got a bit more
complicated I just wanted to tell you
the book so that you can actually get
the understanding of it so I'm telling
you this proof in the simplest case and
actually that was the case that they
were interested in but but the methods
can be extended to General uh and the
question
at least in equivalent formulation was
to estimate the distance of this
Rademacher sum
the sum of all coordinate functions
from the space VN of high frequencies
and of course L2 distance is Trivial
right you cannot approximate such as
some better than just by function zero
right this is just projection on the
space orthogonal production on the space
VN and then of course this distance is
square root of little n
which may be a huge number and during
the talk I would like to to imagine the
capital and as a relatively small number
like 10 or 15 and a little n going to
infinite actually the statement can be
in a way understood in an asymptotic way
when a return goes to Infinity okay so
in air to Norm this is hopeless you
cannot approximate such sum by a
function without
low frequencies other better than just
wave function zero and and this is not a
good approximation okay but the question
was what happens in L1 and this is what
I'm trying to to tell you today so
actually the answer is that up to some
Universal factors
this distance in L1 metric is just
minimum of capital letters
okay so it doesn't go to Infinity when
capital N is fixed it doesn't go to
infinite with a smaller but it just
remains bound at the level of capital
so
and actually there are better bounds so
the same proof that I show you may be
adapted very easily to prove this sort
of estimate
so you will have just maximum of
absolute values of coefficient but
actually it's also not the optimal way
to evaluate this distance in general
situation here here it is but in general
situation in some cases just using hinge
inequality would give a better result by
using this Bond and somehow we can
combine two things and so on and so on
things are getting a bit more
complicated
but I will not go into this detail I
will just try to show you the answer to
this question for this particular
so
okay so now the theorem that will prove
to start with is the following one there
is some Universal positive constant
Kappa such that whatever capital and and
later than we take we can produce a
function on the discrete Cube such that
its expectation is bounded by this
absolute constant times capital n
and such that
the Singleton
indexed Fourier coefficients are equal
to one meaning that you have heard the
markers with coefficients one when you
expand the function in voltrary
expansion and all the remaining
coefficients for cardinality offset a
between zero and capital N should be
zero so all
all low
frequencies disappear only high
frequencies remain
so actually When You Subtract this
Rademacher sum s
that we are interested in from this
function you will get something in the
VN okay so this bound just tells you
that the L1 distance of this Adam Maher
sun is bounded by some Universal
Constantine capital N from the said VN
of functions that have only high
frequencies
right this is just equivalent
formulation instead of say of tracking
how far
VN we perturb this sum by adding some
high frequencies from the end and ask
how small can we make the L1 Norm so of
course this is equivalent statement of
the thing
and also we will see that this order of
magnitude this constant times and bound
cannot be improved now this is the
optimal order and actually when n is
equal to 2 which is the trivial case
somehow we can actually even make
expectation of x equal to one
okay so let's start with the trivial
case
because
that's quite instructive to see how
things develop later on so for capital N
equal to two it's very easy to make such
a function you just take product of all
One Plus RIS subtract product of all one
minus arise so of course
all
odd frequencies will cancel
okay so in particular at level zero and
at level two the full air coefficient
will be equal to zero
okay and on the level one
foreign
this is clearly the function that
satisfies the conditions of our theorem
it has Fourier calculations that
Singleton's equal to one and for zero
and two
in case capital N is equal to for this
cardinalities clearly the coefficient is
disappear so obviously this function
satisfies the conditions and actually
its expectation is equal to one that's
because X equation of this is
one this is one and they have disjoint
support
right this function doesn't disappear
only on one vertex and that on the only
vertex
so the L1 Norm of this function is equal
to one
okay and also you cannot hope at least
in case n equal to two for any better uh
bound on the expectation just because we
want expectation of f multiplied by a
random number equal to one right we want
to read the Fourier coefficient and of
course this implies that expectation of
absolute value of f is greater important
I didn't just pay a point twice
inequality
so
this is the optimal statement okay but
now let's deal with the real true
problem right the what happens when
capital N gets larger how to estimate
this distance in L1 metric in this
situation so now we need to do something
more complicated so the technique that I
will describe the method actually was
used many times before in approximation
theorem and this sort of functions and
approach is used for example involving a
balanced Line's inequality so just to
remind you imagine equality tells you
that when you have a polynomial of
degree n on the interval negative one
one for example then you can bound the
derivative at zero or anywhere in this
interval in absolute value by some
constant times n which is the degree of
the polynomial times the premium of the
value of the polynomial itself so we can
bound the supremum norm of the
derivative on the interval by some
constant depending on the degree
proportional to the degree times the
volume of the value of polynomial itself
okay so somehow this is called better
and somehow the poor that I show you is
in many ways similar to the performance
and for good reasons so let us Define
the following function so this is
function of the fire type so you have
sine functions with increasing
coefficient this is so-called triangle
formation right you have sine X
multiplied by 1 sine two x multiplied by
and so on the coefficients rise in a
linear fashion up to the number n and
then they decrease in linear fashion
after after that okay so we consider
such a function of course functions of
this sort and they like appear in the
proof of fairs they are so
I will call this a function of higher
type
okay and it's very easy to compute some
more compact formula for these functions
of course you can write sine in terms of
exponential function using complex
analysis and then just by simple
exercise in adding trigonometry adding a
geometric
sequences you easily end up with proving
this identity this is very classical
thing so
okay and now we can also control the
size of this function on the interval
minus Pi Pi from two different reasons
so when we are in the interval negative
one over and one over n when X has small
absolute value
this can be bounded by some Universal
constant time N squared and the reason
for that is that this ratio is bounded
from above by n Square just because sine
behaves more or less like a linear
function close to zero and this term is
bounded by one in absolute value right
so you triviality have a bound of these
salts and Universal Constantine and
square on this short interval and
outside this interval we also have a
trivial Bound by some Universal constant
divided by x square now you bound these
two terms from above by one in Trivial
way and you know that sine of x is
greater than x right so
this is
uh
this is the reason for for this sort of
Bound for X greater than one over
and we'll be only interested in the
interval negative Pi Pi so large axis
are not of interest for us so actually
these two bounds
put together mean that the L1 Norm of
this function cyan with respect to lab
back measure uh can be bounded by some
Universal Constantine and okay because
you have first interval of length more
or less one over n where the function is
bounded by constant times and square and
here you have the interval of length
model as one
and
the problem with integration doesn't
exist because you have
this sort of bound and just by trivial
estimating of this integral of this
function you get that this is also known
by con sometimes capital okay so we have
proved that L1 Norm of this function PSI
n is not greater than Universal constant
and capital n
to put this thing on the next slide I I
remind you what we have just proved
and now it's easy to see that this color
product of this function PSI n with sine
X is equal to Pi
why is it so well just because we write
PSI in this step so this is just a
four-year series and you read the
Fourier coefficient standing at the
degree one right so this is a trivial
computation for the same reason this
color product with constant function is
zero and now the thing that is less
obvious is that discover a product with
M's power of sine function is also equal
to zero for all M greater equal than 2
and Below capital n okay so if m is even
this is Trivial PSI n is an odd function
it is just a sum of sine functions it's
all the function so for M even this is
Trivial and now for M odd this is a bit
more complicated so let me explain why
for n odd this holds this is just some
sort of induction so of course all of
you know this identities
enterogenometric identity so we can
express sine X as sub constant times
sine X I've tried this constant is one
sine 3x also some constant plus some
consonants sine five x and so on and so
on and therefore just because this is a
triangular Matrix if you look at this
from the point of linear binary of
linear algebra and this coefficients are
non-zero clearly you can go back and
describe sine MX when m is an odd number
as a linear combination of sine X sine
3x up to sine MX right
so for for your convenience I've written
this formula for sine 5x of course
Computing in particular case ABC is very
easily but now I would like to tell you
why this integration gives zero so this
is of course the same as saying that
this color product
of the design M with this function is
zero so actually here we want to check
that a times 1
plus b times 3 plus c times five
is equal to 0 right
but this is obvious if you look at this
function and this identity at what
happens when X goes to 0.
so sine Phi of X when you divide it by X
will go to zero and of course you know
that sine 3x divided by X will go to 3
sine 5x divided by X will go to 5 and so
on so you later just in one line what
you need and the same works for other
functions right so this trivial
observation proves that that actually
that actually this integral is equal to
zero and of course this will not work
for m equal to 1 just because then the
left hand side sine X after regarding by
X doesn't go to zero but it goes to one
okay so that's why odd m equal to 1 is
an exceptional case so all higher odd
numbers the integral will be equal to
zero
but for m equal to what we have an
exception
okay so now we finish actually our proof
so we Define function f of x on the
discrete Cube defining it by this
formula we integrate the interval minus
Pi Pi and normalize
PSI n of X and here we consider a
product of one plus r i sine X
and this product we integrate with
respective
to DX
so there is one nice thing about this
formula
just
uh
because sine doesn't take values outside
negative one one interval these things
are non-negative
okay
so when we try to estimate the L1 Norm
of F this is just reduced to estimating
the L1 Norm of function PSI n and this
bound tells us that exactly we bound the
other one Norm of function f on the
Discord Cube by constant times capital n
so we reduce the problem of finding L1
Norm to what happens on the description
what happens here and this is Trivial
and on the other hand we can ask and
what about frequencies thus this
function f defined in this way satisfy
our main assumption that all frequencies
0 2 3 up to capital N disappear and the
answer is Trivial just when you multiply
everything with everything and you use
the fact that integral is a linear
functional you end up
seeing that the coefficient is standing
at a wall indexed by SATA a is PSI n of
x times the power of sine which is
cardinality of the set a integrated over
interval minus Pi Pi but we chose
function PSI n exactly in such a way
that all these coefficients will
disappear except in the case of an of
the cardinality of the SATA a being
equal to one okay so we just chose
function PSI n in such a way to kill all
these coefficients
okay
that's long as the end and those of you
who know poor sub version inequity
consider this is actually sort of
transverse proof of operations
inequality in
the digital Cube setting
so now
to discuss the optimality of the bound
so now let's consider the cube negative
1 1 of degree of of Dimension n Square
and we will prove that on cube of this
size
every function that satisfies our
conversions namely for single Returns
the
Fourier coefficients are equal to one
and for all other A's of the size 0 2 3
4 up to capital N the Fourier
coefficient disappear that whenever we
take such function then expectation must
be greater than some Universal constant
times capital N okay which shows that in
particular that in the previous theorem
the capital of an
bound was optimal that you cannot do
better okay so now of course we want to
prove it for every function
and then we're satisfied just showing an
example of single function then now yes
so you're saying you have to prove it
for every function but in fact it's not
true that it's enough to show it for
symmetric functions like that are
because
yeah well at least at least in the
statements because coefficient sending
at all the mahals are equal to one the
thing is symmetric and of course you can
never stick to symmetric yes
yes and when you do it that these kind
of things are known like yes and this is
actually what will happen yeah I don't
claim that this is an uh any difficult
uh here and but actually the proof that
I will show can be extended to
non-symmetric situation and then it
works as well whereas the the thing that
we are talking about uh wouldn't
wouldn't apply so so naturally yeah but
all right here because of this matter of
the coefficients actually we can reduce
things very easily to what dimensional
thinking and use a very well known facts
yeah
and this particular is proving proving
the Bounce from below is is quite easy
but the proof that I will show you here
uh has the advantage of being uh
accentable to General case
and also I think it has some some nice
feature of its own okay so now let's
consider two functions so we have some
fixed capital n and we want to prove
that when you have function satisfying
this condition we want to prove this
lower amount
so to do that we Define two functions WN
is just a polynomial
this is a finite sub and here are only
power function so this is some
polynomial of degree at most capital n
and this is some infinite series but
it's very nicely convergent just because
these denominators increase very quickly
and of course when you put these two
things together you just get the series
for the sign function right so this is a
trivial observation and also for t
for T and the argument T that is between
n over 6 with minus and one over six we
can very easily bound the absolute value
of this function of this tail part
and prove that this is not greater than
2 in power minus negative n just
estimated in a very brutal way
term by term isn't triangle inequality
and using the trivial estimate
showing that M factorial is greater than
M over in power so when you do that
triple computation you end up seeing
that this thing on this interval is
negligible
okay on the other hand
this implies
that WN
on this interval is bounded Say by 2.
right just because these two functions
together give sine function that is
bounded by one and we know that this
second factor is very small right so
this means that this polynomial WN is
bounded for example by two actually you
can of course improve this bound to some
inverse close to one
will not need that
okay so this justifies this inequality
two times first absolute moment of f
obviously dominates this quantity just
because the absolute value of WN on this
polynomial is bounded by two on this
interval and we only need to know what
happens on this interval just because we
end up n square plus minus ones and
divide by n
and six right so clearly whatever value
these are the Mahal functions take
always this normalized sum will lie in
this interval okay so the bound can be
applied we have this trivial estimate
here but now on the other hand I claim
that we can replace function f in this
expectation just by sum of Radars r i
why well that's just because the
coefficients in the virtual
expansion of function f are exactly as
in the world through the expansion of
this function right this is our
assumption about F that all four
coefficients with uh sets a of
cardinality 0 to 3 up to Capital and
disappear
and at cardinality one they are ones so
these two functions F and this sum have
the same all Fourier
uh
uh expansion at the levels up to capital
n
but it's not not important what happens
for higher degrees just because WN is a
polynomial of degree at most n so when
you take a polynomial in random random
variables you compute everything
multiply and so on things may cancel out
but actually you will get just a world
fully expansion of this thing and no
wall functions of degree higher than n
will appear right
so for this trivial reason we have
equality we can just replace our
function I've made this order without
changing the value of this color product
okay but now this quantity can be very
easily estimated From Below
just because
you replace WN by sine minus function RN
this part is technological just because
we know the function R and uh is bounded
on on this interval
so this time goes very quickly to zero
and as for this function we know very
easily how to compute radham sine of
something expression right so first
because of symmetry that's the only
point at which we actually use symmetry
here but in general proof in general
situation of course you do that step
differently so
because of symmetry you have just n
Square
terms of this form and then it's very
easy to compute this expression right so
you condition over R1 you just split
into cases R1 equal to one and R1 equal
to negative one and then you end up just
by Computing characteristic function of
this thing
which leaves you at this expression but
of course the size of this expression is
very easy this behaves like one over n
and here you have one minus one over n
Square modulus in power and square so
distance to constant so all together
this behaves like up to some Universal
Factor like capital N okay so we have
bounded from below expectation
of absolute value of a capital cons by
Universal consent and capital okay now
this proof can be easily modified to all
small and greater equal than n square
instead of exactly equal this is just a
small modification and the case when
little run is below one square which is
not very interesting case also easily
follows I will skip that the slides will
be preserved so if you want to track
details you will have this slide
and also we have a napper bound that is
Trivial just by tensioning it's not
exactly kitchen it's just comparison of
first and second moment right when uh
when
little n is very small it's below
capital N squared then you can just
bound this distance in a one metric by
the distance in our two metric which is
trigger and this ends the proof of this
approximately call it okay the other
cases have triggered the difficult part
is what I showed you in detail the other
things just follow in a few lines
okay
so I think I have about 20 minutes
remaining right yes yes
let me now pass to the second subject so
this is the thing that I talked about at
several conferences so far so I just
would like to excuse those of you who've
heard this thing talked about once and
again several times but somehow I
decided that because there is a lot of
Boolean analysis audience here and
apparently not everyone heard about
these results so maybe I should just
repeat some basic things so there is
this classical theorem by Future now
which to authors are here and awesome
probably not uh
and
there are many ways to face this CRM I
will raise it in the following way there
is this a universal positive constant C
such that whatever n you take and
whatever Boolean function on the
discrete you take
you can bound
the L2 distance between F and function
Tree by this expression where G is of
especially particularly simple form so
it's either random marker function or
minus or the Mahal function or just one
or negative
okay so the
there is this collection is very simple
Boolean functions function that is
constant one constant negative one
and plus minus coordinate function right
so together there are not so many of
them and what is in common between this
function all of them are both Boolean
and effin functions right when you look
at the discrete Cube as part of RN you
can obviously say what ahine functions
are affine functions are the functions
for which all these Fourier coefficients
for
cardinality greater important to
disappear
okay you all mean it the only thing that
remains if you consider a fine function
is constant
part and some linear combination
so
this is very easy to prove that if a
function is both Boolean and a fine then
it must be just one of those functions
this is the triviality
what was the real achievement of filter
color and now was proving that if
function is close to f i in the sense
that sum of the is quite a clear
coefficient on higher than one
frequencies
if this is small then F must be close to
a function of this particular form okay
so this is some sort of stability result
you know how to solve the exact question
and then you ask and what if I pair if I
relax conditions and instead of
insisting that all this foliar
coefficient Disappear Completely you
just ask that the mass on these high
frequencies is contour and then the
answer is that
then F must be close and in proportional
distance to this quantity
from one of those simple functions and
actually the first proof was there were
two poles and writer gaikinland provided
a different proof and also with many
extensions and two slightly better
bounds and so on okay so now I would
like just to discuss a few recent
extensions to this fkn
theorem as it is called now
and they were obtained in my drawing
paper with yazakiandre and Jacob
both at that time were also at Warsaw
University but now the other Kinder is
in Paris in a company technique and yeah
Works in Google
the academic drop but I think he's still
doing some computer science so probably
some of you might have heard about his
his work in in computer science
okay and we hope that the paper
containing this result that I will just
sketch very briefly will appear in the
theory of computing soon
it's conditionally accepted we still
have to change presentations so I hope
it will be
published soon
okay so now I would like to describe the
main trick that we use in this paper and
I I would like just to phrase it in a
very general way so first step in the
proof and that was already in the fkn
paper the original one it's very trivial
so instead of considering the Boolean
function you're describing the proof
with the describe the result
the
proof of this no I I describe the
general framework and then I will state
there are several results that will be
used that will use this fabric
okay of course I'm not able to present
all proofs statements
yeah I'll just show some statement but I
also want to somehow tell you the basic
general idea that underlies this new
this new proof which I think is good to
understand
uh what what is new in this approach
okay so first step is uh very classical
and that was already in this first paper
and that's quite obvious right you start
with this Boolean function f and you
replace it by its projection to to the
space of a fine functions right you
replace it by by the closest in Alto
Norm effin function you can find to it
which is just
you take walls functions with fully
coefficients of f but up to the
frequency one up to the level one okay
so you just because it's much easier to
study regular functions like Rademacher
sounds than to study a general Boolean
function okay so the first step is that
actually what we'll study is we'll study
this sort of a fine functions and prove
that if they take value in some way
close to a Boolean function f that we
started with then you can learn
something about these coefficients okay
that's that's the most natural first
step you take advantage of the fact that
you know that your Boolean function life
is close to an affine function and then
you study the defined function instead
just because it's more regular and you
read properties of the coefficients of
this I find function from what you
assume about this closeness to some
Boolean tension life that you started
so that's the first step quite obvious
one and now the step two that I want to
to advertise here so this is a very
general very vague statement but that's
the main idea so we'll prove dilemma of
the following form we have two
independent random variable centers and
Y
and we will prove that if there are some
X Plus Y is concentrated in some way
then at least one of these variables X
and Y
is concentrated in some other way
this is very vague and that's for a good
purpose because it will cover a very
huge range of things that you can do
with this scheme so this way of
concentration is different than that one
and this is just an example just to give
you something to keep your mind on so
here what I call
uh quotes concentrated is this sort of
concentration so what does it mean that
the variance of absolute value X Plus Y
is small this means that absolute value
X Plus Y
is in some way close to a constant
function
says some number a but what does it mean
it means that X Plus Y is in some way
concentrated around a two point set
negative a a right so this is this sort
of concentration that we'll have in mind
when speaking about this expression
right so this means that X Plus Y is
close to some two point set in in a very
vague sense
thus in this particular example you can
even imagine much
more General framework and what does it
mean that X or Y are concentrated well
this is just usual concentration in
terms of having small values right so
this is example of the statement that we
will prove and of course depending on
what llama you proof of this form the
further proof will proceed along
different ways right but this is the
starting point proving calama of this of
this form you prove that if sum is
concentrated in some way then at least
one of those variables X and Y must be
concerned in some other way and
sometimes of course you will assume some
additional properties about those X and
Y or we will assume something additional
about the sum itself whatever right but
the general framework is like that
okay now the step three that is the the
real Innovation is the following one so
now you take some note of two summons
but you have n terms and independent
variables X1 up to x n
and you deduce the statement for n
variables from the statement for two
very variables and now I claim that if
the whole sum of all variables is
concentrated in this
right hand side of our equality sense
then there exists a single K between 1
and n
so that when you drop the X
term from the sum X summoned the sum of
remaining random variables will be
concentrated in this sense that we had
on the left hand side of our inequate
and we do it in the following way this
is very trivial thing and of course I
don't claim that this is a discovery I
mean this sort of reasoning was probably
used hundreds of time before so the only
Innovation here is that somehow or maybe
that's the first time Juanito's Anderson
that you can apply this to fkn CRM and
segments of this cell but of course the
reasoning is very simple so we look for
some subset of bracket n s i is the sum
of X I's with indices falling to this
set I this is a partial sum and now we
choose a minimal set I minimal in the
sense of inclusion such that s i is
already not concentrated in this left
hand side sense okay
so I say a minimal just because it
doesn't have to be any determined so
there might be several options but we
choose a minimal eye such that this is
not concentrated this part in particular
implies data is not empty because
otherwise the sum would be empty and
that would be just zero so whatever
sense of concentration you consider
constant 0 is well concentrated right so
I is not empty so choose any absolutely
any K falling into this non-empty set I
and now use the thing that we had in
step two
this statement
for power of variables X which is just
some index by this minimal set I
and Y which is the sum of all remaining
X
sub take bracket and minus
Etc
okay so when you add X and Y you get the
whole sum again
and by our assumption
this is concentrated
and by the choice of I the summoned X is
not concentrated right we chose minimal
set a such that this s i is not
concentrated so the Step 2 says that one
of those is concentrated so because we
know that X isn't then Y Must Be
concentrated
okay we did use this from step two
and also when you dropped from I
the case summoned the remaining sum
already is concentrated just because we
chose I to be minimal set
uh
such that this is non-concentrated and
any smaller set already will be
concentrated
so in particular this one okay because
it's contained in the set a and not
equal to okay
so now we can express the sum of all
variables except the decade one just as
some of these two sums and we know about
this that this is star concentrated and
this is star concentrated so under any
reasonable understanding of
concentration
the sum of two concentrated and things
is also concentrated okay because this
is a slippery part and somehow omitting
technical details that appear in all
particular applications of this idea but
the idea is that you can deduce the
statement for n variables just from
properly formulated Lemma for two
variables okay and there is huge
potential for extension and modification
and I as I said I'm sure that this way
of reasoning was used of hundreds of
time before in many situations but for
example concentration might be replaced
by some sort of smallness in this
reasoning and also instead of some food
one can make consider Maxima and so on
and so on but in our in our works we
concentrated uh we really worked in this
Edition when things are concentrated and
actually we consider sounds and still a
number of
possible extensions possible direction
that you can follow is immense so so we
got many results I will just show you a
very quick collection of of some of them
so one of them is we start with this
form of Lemma so here this variance of
the absolute value of some and this is
under assumption that one of variables X
and Y is symmetric so when you add the
Symmetry assumption that at least one of
those variables X and Y is symmetric
then you can prove this sort of Lemma
with this constant
and then you deduce exactly in the way
that I described a moment ago the
following statement when you have any
sequence of Independence symmetrical
variables then you can drop a single
summon so that the variance of all the
remaining will be controlled by the
variance of absolute
uh
value of the hollow sum and even if you
shifted by some constant okay so
actually this helps with quite good
concerns so this holds with constant
which is two times this constant so this
is like 5.6
and there is a simple example of three
radamaha showing that in this theorem
you cannot go with the constant below
2.7 sorry so actually the constant that
you get by this method is not very far
from optimal that's probably another
advantage of this approach
no no and I think it's more or less
hopeless so I know exactly what one can
do to improve the concern so one could
prove this sort of Lemma
that that is later used not for two
variables but for three variables for
example and try to apply the same trick
starting not from lemon for two variable
but for three but you know even proving
this isn't very simple
and
I guess improving this constant is a
terrible thing and I don't think there
is any reason to believe that there is a
nice and a nice quantity that that also
appears but I don't know perhaps this is
just the optimal one but I I don't see
any strong reason to be like that
okay so actually this result contains
the FK NCR and plus a special case when
you take care of the maker functions
with some
real coefficients so from this the fkn
CRM follows immediately
why just because you look at this you
remember the first step we reduce our
Boolean function on the cube to its
projection to the defining function and
then you investigate properties of this
function exactly using this CRM
and the assumptions from fkn tell you
that this side is small which means that
variance of this of this affine function
is small which tells you that all
coefficients except one disappear right
and this leaves with one random 100 with
plus or minus one or with a constant
plus minus one actually okay so I I
don't want to get into details but but
this is very easy to read fkn from this
statement and actually on the discount
Cube we are able to get some much
stronger quantitative bound which was
also independently found by Ryan
McDonald but this other proof is
completely of the third nature using
hypercontractivity and
and some sort of self-improving bound
it's not very complicated but but it's
of different nature
okay and now another
another thing that we can improve so now
let X and Y be Independents just score
integrable to make integrals make sense
and now
assume that you can bound this quantity
then you can prove that the variance of
X or variance of Y is bounded by some
linear expression in a row not quadratic
but linear we are losing something but
actually this cannot be done better and
then in the way that I describe you get
the following bound
and actually it's easy to prove that
this
transition from raw Square to row cannot
be avoided
okay so again you have the same sort of
statement that you drop on summoned and
you have the band but because you don't
assume anything about the variables
previous relation that they are
symmetric you get a weaker bound okay so
those of you who attended the avid's
Rubinstein talks several days ago recall
that there was a different sort of bound
that he discussed and actually
we have
well we didn't do it in our paper just
because we are intercepting this
normalization but actually this is just
one line changing the both so when you
look at the proof of this lever here the
way we prove this Lemma is we establish
two quantities Alpha and beta
which are some quite quite easy
probability the title probabilities so
we established two quantities Alpha that
is comparable to variance of X and the
beta that is comparable to variance of Y
and we prove which is like one line
proof more or less but this is bounded
by some constant
so of course from this you immediately
introduced that one of them must be
below row more or less and from this you
get you get this assertion but actually
if you
agree to add one more parameter to the
game
namely you assume that you control the
variance of the sum
which is sum of variances obviously then
you know
that at least one of these two variances
must be of the same size models as the
whole variance right at least one half
of it
which territory that one of these
numbers must be at least of the order of
magnitude of the whole variance and this
immediately gives you the bound of this
sort okay and if you translate it you
get you get the statement that is not
exactly the
inequality that habit was that was
talking about but gives the same
conclusion about Boolean function and uh
I guess that is some sort of equivalent
if you if you look more carefully but
but at least it looks different but it
gives exactly the same consequence for
Boolean functions on the cube so somehow
this to statement are just different
normalization right you add additional
parameter and you control things better
but somehow
forwarding this Rubinstein type bound is
stronger which is obvious because you
control things using two parameters
instead of one right but somehow getting
this bounds from our boundaries just by
adding one line to the proof of this
Rama and
and just to finish I'm out of time
already
more or less and out of time so I will
just end up there is a statement about
what happens in Banner space and I will
not talk about because I'm out of time
and you can go to this right and see it
this also more or less that when things
in Banner space are concerted around
some finite number of points then
actually you can when the sum of
independent random vectors is consulted
around some finite number of points then
you can drop almost all summons
uh you might drop only small number of
summons and the sum of the remaining
ones will be very strongly concentrated
very close to constant okay so it's
slightly different in fkn you
concentrate around two point side so you
drop only one salmon
here you have more general setting in
Banner space and you can drop a number
of summon that is not greater than the
number of points around which you assume
the concentration and then the remaining
part is negligible this is close to cons
this is this sort of statement and I I
just would like to find end with the
open question which is completely
dramatic has nothing to do with
probability and Boolean analysis but I
think this is a nice question
so you have two finite subsets in a
non-linear space
you may assume that it is finite
dimensional of course because these are
finite sets and they are one separated
meaning that any two points in when you
take set a and the two points of this
set are separated by a distance of at
least one and the same for the sub B
and now the question is can you find in
the minkowski sum a plus b some subset c
with Cardinal integrated equal
non-cardinality of a plus cardinality of
B minus 1 which is also one separate
this is an extension of koshy Davenport
sort of in some sense okay and we proved
it in hearable spaces and the proof is
not very difficult and the question is
does it hold in one lock spaces and we
don't have an idea so it's easy to
perform the cardinality of one of the
cells is equal to two this is very easy
but when both of them have three
elements we already don't know what the
answer is and I I personally assume that
maybe there is some counter example if
both of them have just three elements
but
things get very complicated in general
space but I think this is a nice open
question that's of more general interest
of course if you know anything about the
history of this question that I also
would like to know because perhaps we
are breaking through an Open Door
thank you very much and sorry for
any questions
asked me the same question
but you are asking about uh
the first thing
uh that's a very natural thing to
consider further on and some things are
quite easy just because you have some
sort of comparisons between Norms like
engine inequalities
but some aspects are more delicate and
actually I don't think what was done
here actually answers what happens in LP
in general for p between one and two
from P greater than two things are
simple just because you can compare
piece normally if second one and I think
the non-trivial question appears when
you go with P to Infinity because then
of course engine inequality explodes and
then you can again ask about the level
of approximation so but there is even
much similar question even in L1 that
that is completely urbanizing and I
don't see how to extend these methods so
my girl should ask this question so you
can start not with her son but with
degree 2 uh
works for your house right
you started with something called a flow
frequency but not not the purely file
but some other two chaos
what is the best approximation I don't
have an idea
uh and this method definitely doesn't
transfer in the direct form and also the
question the same in L1 Norm but
assuming that the coefficients are
vectors assume that you have a
functional Boolean cube with values in
vectors
and even foreign this proof will not
transfer you see it uses a lot of
algebraic properties that you can
multiply
but in general I don't think
it does this session it's a new light
only
okay quicker than
this I don't really think I think it's a
different sort of thing right because
you are allowed to perturb this Adam
only by high frequencies but you don't
put a resolution on the size of
coalitions so I think that's a
completely different way of perturbing
function right you don't assume that you
only assume that low frequencies
Disappear Completely except the degree
one but then you don't say anything
about high fragments right I think I
mean
and I was asked also this question that
Virgin Islands confirmed and I don't
think this methodology that we
introduced actually allows to pass to
this extension that were done by Guy
Kindra and muri Safra no I I don't think
I think this is a very specific uh
I think these tricks that I described
here are very specific to to sums and
probably higher order than chaos well
perhaps you can do that but with a lot
of additional machinery
maybe one should just think about that
and somehow the Fourier analytic proof
that I said that recently was done then
of course this thing stands for much
nicer but the question is do you want to
do things only on the cube on marginal
product spaces
so this progress works for general
public places but most things
alongside long lines of broken CRM are
done on discrete coupons with methods
that are very specific so
probably
part of things can be transfers
okay thanks